bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver ça y est
c'est fait l'annoncé a eu lieu en fin
d'après midi on va prendre le temps dans
cette émission d'analysé le premier
gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes pap
ndiaye à l'éducation nationale c'est la
surprise du chef catherine colonna au
quai d'orsay parmi les nouveaux visages
et puis olivier dussopt pts au travail
qui sera chargé de l'explosive réforme
des retraites les permanences les
entrants les sortants la parité les
équilibres politiques grand débat
spécial remaniement dans un enfant avec
nos invités puis dans la deuxième partie
on va retrouver nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris les infos coulisses des âmes
ou d'un gars va sur la campagne des
législatives le regard européen de
richard wehrli sur notre première
ministre et puis l'économie avec fanny
guinochet à quand le gel des loyers face
à l'inflation qui frappe de plein fouet
les locataires modestes voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs 26 jours après
l'élection d' emmanuel macron les
français oat enfin un nouveau
gouvernement il ya de la stabilité mais
s'est conjuguée avec quelques surprises
et parfois de taille on va analyser tout
cela avec voir nos bd des t-bonds soir
et et merci d'être là professeur associé
à l'université paris sorbonne rédacteur
en chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire sophie de ravinel
bienvenue soit vous êtes journaliste
politique au figaro vous suivez entre
autres la gauche et même la nuque mais
on veut l'entendre jean luc mélenchon
dans cette émission parce que sa
réaction est intéressante bonsoir savait
rien aux jec bon ça ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau journalistes
politiques éditorialistes notamment à
france info et vous venez de publier
résurrection chez stock c'est le récit
des coulisses des derniers mois due
d'abord président puis candidat emmanuel
macron donc jusqu'à sa réélection et
puis et milita palce kick et
communicante spécialiste de la
communication politique va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant on
déroge pas à la règle c'est vous qui
ouvrait le bal stéphane blakowski qui
entre qui sort quelles sont les
surprises votre regard si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
alors on y va si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris on nous avait
promis pour ce nouveau gouvernement un
effet whaou le truc qui vous sider
vraiment donc là on a un nouveau
ministre de l'éducation qui donc à fait
normale sup oui d'accord il est agrégé
d'histoire bah oui il est prof à
sciences po dont bhl a jusqu'à présent
ça n'a rien de très surprenant mais
quand on nous dit après tout quand on
découvre plutôt que par médias et en
étant ministre de l'éducation en plus et
noir alors là whaou alors je sais on
devrait pas et n'aura pas être surpris
parce que la france cette grande
république où tout le monde a sa chance
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau et
pourtant on est quand même surpris donc
je sais que ce n'est peut-être pas si
clair on est aussi surpris ya pas que la
couleur de peau stéphane on est surpris
par un changement de ligne politique non
alors allez vite c'est ça plutôt ça la
vraie surprise parce que pendant le
premier quinquennat macron pape dieye a
régulièrement pris position en tant
qu'intellectuel il n'était pas toujours
d'accord avec les gouvernants par
exemple pour 2017 lui dire oui en france
il ya un racisme structurel dans une
interview dont on ne sait pas du tout ce
qu'on dit au gouvernement puis ça allait
au delà il a aussi parlé des violences
policières ça c'était en 2020 sur france
inter on écoute
l'attitude de déni en ce qui concerne
les violences policières en france et
est tout à fait classique et depuis
longtemps il y aurait des violences
policières aux états unis en france il y
en a pas puisqu'on vous dit qu'il n'y en
a pas et d'ailleurs nous sommes en
république alors est-ce qu'il va
continuer à dire qu'il ya des volants
soleil en france voici le du conseil des
ministres et qu'à côté de lui et gérald
darmanin la la dotant de donc voilà il
reste à l'intérieur un ça fait partie
des stabilité de ce nouveau gouvernement
darmanin à l'intérieur exactement sa
partie de ceux qui conservent leur
ministère il ya aussi bruno le maire qui
reste à l'économie dupond moretti qui
reste à la justice alors qu'on ne s'y
attendait pas forcément puis après il ya
tout un petit jeu de chaises musicales
les mêmes ministres reste au
gouvernement mais à un autre poste donc
et comme des promotions là dedans je
crois que la plus belle promotion c'est
celle de sébastien lecornu qui devient
ministre de la défense toujours
passionné par les militaires depuis tout
le voilà depuis sa tendre enfance s'il
aimait jocky soldats feuilles il va
pouvoir jouer la taille réelle donc
c'est il était aux trois maires donc ça
c'est elle brûlé qui est parti pour
accumuler des miles et ce tout au moins
de sa famille sera avec nous en direct
tout à l'heure on est enfermé en parlera
et donc aprilia brigitte bourguignon qui
elle était à l'autonomie qui a une vraie
promotion qui devient ministre de la
santé donc on doit aller ailleurs il va
ou aux relations avec le parlement donc
plutôt plutôt en coulisses et marc
raynaud qui est au parle de cette
relation du problème en lui arrive à
l'agriculture et ça se renouvelle pas
vraiment réalité je viens de normandie
lui n'est pas dans le casting mais je
précise que il l'a choisi et voyons ce
président-là président pourquoi je
faisais voilà donc mais il a expliqué
d'ailleurs que c'était un choix
personnel peut-être retrouver retrouver
sa famille l'écologie dans tout ça elle
est représentée par keith taylor avait
dit
écologique ou ne sera pas donc tout son
quinquennat repose sur deux femmes en
espagne et une hache et qui va s'occuper
de la transition énergétique et amélie
de montchanin qui va elle s'occupait de
la transition écologique dans les
territoires qui parlait dé des
promotions tout alors il ya gabriella
talent qui a une belle promotion puisque
deux portants il devient ministre du
budget comme d'autres de ses grands
prédécesseurs nicolas sarkozy sa copie
ce qui passe par budget généralement de
grandes ambitions et leurs qui va
devenir porte-parole fait une femme
olivia grégoire pourquoi est ce qu'on
l'a choisi parce que quand il s'agit de
parler elle n'a rien ne lui fait peur
surtout pas françois ruffin on écoute
non non non non mais chez rue forest
lawn alors monsieur rufin vous allez
baissé d'un ton vous avez quatre minutes
je voulais cette émission spéciale
on vient matière et dispose d'une voix
qui peut être largement supérieure à la
vôtre on a quatre minutes ça s'est
toujours passé ainsi ça fait quatre fois
je vous reprends à l'ordre maintenant je
vous demande de vous taire les autres
reprennent la sorte et monsieur rufin
voilà elle est allée à grégoire
finalement il n'y a pas énormément de
nouveau dans ce gouvernement pas tant
que cela n'est pas une surprise ça
pourrait être stanislas guéri mais enfin
c'est pas un nouveau visage il est nommé
à la fonction publique ok c'est un peu
un
un nouveau ministre sans doute qui aura
un peu d'importance mais est ce qu'on
est surpris est-ce que c'est waou non
pas à la limite il ya peine deux
surprises qu'on traîne avec elle alors
je dirais je vais devoir lire son nom
rime à abdoul il ce que j'ai entendu que
mes colères d abdoul malek est donc la
nouvelle ministre de la culture mais en
même temps c'est pas vraiment une
surprise puisque wii et de l'aube se
disait de l'an dernier qu'elle était
déjà mise de la culture en fait elle
tirait toutes les ficelles dans l'ombre
est embêté roselyne bachelot avec cet
ailleurs multicolores devant donc ça
c'est une surprise mais pour le grand
public et puis il ya quand même un
mystère très important le quai d'orsay
qui revient à catherine colonna alors
c'est l'ancien porte parole de jacques
chirac est resté à 10 ans il ne nous
rajeunit pas mais surtout une vraie
diplomate elle est ambassadrice en
italie elle était à ce moment là au
royaume uni puis elle a été ministre des
affaires européennes sous le
gouvernement villepin en 2005 voyelles
et là est-ce que vous la voyez c'est un
petit jeu où la repérer ou pas non
derrière ben
oui on n'est pas tellement de
changements d'un gouvernement à l'autre
en revanche en quinze ans on voit quand
même quelque chose qui a franchement
changé c'est tout c'est monsieur en
costume gris quand même là il ya un peu
de parité qui sait même plus me ferai
part de paris texas et d'un gouvernement
donc ça c'est quand même un changement
aboutisse et c'est un vrai progrès il y
avait juste alliot marie qui n'avait mis
qu'un portable ça aurait été trop déçu
de mettre une jupe ou une robe merci
beaucoup merci stéphane je crois qu'on a
vraiment été assez assez complet on va
revenir sur le cas pap ndiaye parce que
c'est vraiment la surprise ce soir mais
d'abord j'aimerais un premier tour de
table j'aimerais votre votre impression
générale c'est vrai que on se dit du
tout continuité stabilité que nouveauté
est ce que vous voyez les choses comme
ça oui absolument rien j'ai plutôt des
mêmes des techniciens sont des gens qui
savent faire comme d'ailleurs elisabeth
bornes c'est quelqu'un qui sait faire
qui sait gérer les dossiers on voit le
duo effectivement en charge de la
planification écologique gens que ça ça
illustre très bien l' architecture
globale de ce gouvernement c'est la mer
une à shane williams et leigh de
montchalin ces deux techniciennes ses
terres c'est une écologie de résultats
on n'est plus du tout dans l'affichage
dont la prise de guerre
on serait allé chercher yannick jadot ou
à l'époque c'était nicolas il serait pas
leur faute et confessionnelles
s'attaquer place et des techniciens cdc
des sachants alors après il ya
évidemment quelques nouvelles têtes il
ya quelques surprises la plus grosse
surprise la plus grosse prise de guerre
la plus grosse surprise est le plus gros
risque pardon c'est papa ni rien on va
en parler longuement ce qu'on va en
parler juste peut-être une coloration
assez féminine que je trouve assez
intéressante une femme première ministre
et une porte-parole également femmes au
ministère des affaires étrangères
ministère de l'europe est également une
femme donc je trouve que voilà il ya un
coût à ce point de vue là on pourra dire
la des postes importants voilà que les
femmes sont relégués au poste subalterne
s'est pas complètement ça bonsoir emile
et les habits et merci d'être là 11 en
trop sur un total de 27 minutes ministre
délégué secrétaire d'état pas énorme
vous voyez les choses comme ça aussi oui
surtout qu'on avait quand même un
président qui le soir de son élection et
sa victoire nous a dit président nouveau
quinquennat nouveau peuple le nouveau
peuple nouveau j'ai pas compris mais en
tout cas on comprenait la promesse de il
avait dit ça sera pas c'est pas le même
quinquennat c'est pas le même président
bah c'est la même équipe globalement
c'est vrai qu'il ya une petite surprise
au ministère de l'éducation nationale
avec un virage complètement
va globalement les crocs poids lourds
sont là ils sont restés bruno le maire
au même ministère gérald darmanin au
même ministère eric dupond moretti et
même si les mises en examen dont il ya
même de la continuité là dessus c'est à
dire que les promesses de 2017 elles
sont toujours pas tenue eric
dupond-moretti reste à la justice on a
quand même quelque chose qui est d'ordre
d'une véritable continuité alors
peut-être que c'est une écologie plus
pratique plus méthodologique et on peut
se dire que elisabeth bornes en effet
c'est quelqu'un qui a l'air d'avancer ne
jamais renoncer à ses réformes donc ça
c'est peut-être là tout réformateur
d'emmanuel macron et on peut se dire
s'ils allaient réformatrice autant que
ce qu'elle a fait pour la réforme de la
sncf et la réforme de l'assurance
chômage si elle le fait sur l'écologie
ou sur la grande cause du quinquennat
qui est aussi la même grande cause que
premier quinquennat les violences faites
aux femmes et l'égalité hommes femmes si
elle réussit pourquoi pas mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya pas de signaux on
attendait quand même ce souffle on a eu
quand même un emmanuel macron qui nous a
fait beaucoup de cinéma à marseille
dans l'entre-deux tours sur l'écologie
juste avant il l'avait fait sur le
social en dix ans qui finalement réforme
des retraites on ferait peut-être
autrement et puis là tout d'un coup ça
retombe beaucoup il n'y a pas tellement
de nouveau souffle c'est vraiment la
continuité arnaud belle et si on prend
les mêmes et on recommence quand on
regarde le régalien on se dit tiens
c'est plus à droite comme en défense
merci
intérieure quand on regarde le social le
madec voilà les grosses réformes
attendues 1 de ce deuxième quinquennat
les retraites la santé l'hôpital c'est
plus à gauche voyez ça comme ça oui
j'allais vous répond que cela
c'est-à-dire qu'on ait fait quand ton
regard de la constitution de ce
gouvernement et quand on regarde les
équilibres droite gauche on voit que
pour ce qui concerne le régalien à
l'économie en effet il a préféré nommer
des ministres de droite sur le social
c'est plutôt des ministres de gauche
avec notamment madame bourguignon et du
soap qui s'occupera des retraites il ya
quand même damien abad qui sera ministre
de la solidarité et qui constitue quand
même pour lui une prise de guerre
relative parce que c'est pas une
surprise c'est la seule et puis alors il
a essayé quand même d'en revenir un
logiciel qui est le logiciel sur les
questions de société me semble-t-il
c'est à dire c'est très intéressant sur
l'éducation et la culture il fait appel
à des personnalités qui sont des
personnalités issues de la diversité
comme s'il fallait donner un signal
d'une certaine façon à cet électorat là
dont il peut considérer que cet
électorat à voter par exemple que
finalement il il récupère sur la gauche
à travers ce signal là sinon sur le fond
c'est le même esprit c'est à dire c'est
la continuité de 2010 est avec un
équilibre entre les ministres
techniciens et des ministres politique
est à peu près équivalent à celui qu'on
a connu jusqu'à maintenant donc ya pas
fondamentalement de changement avant de
terminer le tour de table avec avec vous
ce fils de ravinel jean luc mélenchon
que vous connaissez bien écouter ce
qu'il en a pensé de cette nouvelle
équipe sous les 1 par an ce terme est
grise sans audace
et de peu d'entrain on retrouve les
principales figures
de la maltraitance sociale et de
l'irresponsabilité écologique du
précédent gouvernement alain toute chose
ce sera donc le pire c'est-à-dire la
continuité voilà elle n'a rien
d'étonnant elle est extrêmement violente
déjà à peine nommés n'ont pas commencé
ça vous surprend pas donc ça ne surprend
pas puisque c'est de l'intérim et que le
prochain premier c'est lui donc dans son
état d'esprit pour lui c'est lui le
prochain ils ne sont là que en attendant
sa victoire législative une
vague une vague multicolore avec tout le
monde le v de la victoire à l'assemblée
donc voilà on y est pas encore sommes
pour l'instant effectivement sa réaction
est extrêmement dur extrêmement dur
aussi vis-à-vis de papy niayes qu'il a
quand même traité de renégats à l'égal
de
damien abad en disant cette autre
renégats pour l'accuser d'avoir
abandonné la gauche screg a tragiquement
absolument trahi la gauche alors après
tout de suite dès que j'ai j'ai tweeté
cette réaction parce que j'ai trouvé ça
quand même énorme ils m'ont dit mais non
mais non il ne s'agissait pas de
critiquer pap ndiaye l'entourage de jean
luc mélenchon je suis dit écoutez je
suis désolé écouter les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon il s'agit bien de lui
dont il parle je pense que ça a été un
coup effectivement parce que c'est un
bon coup on en parlera alors on y va je
vous redonne la parole parce que je me
reprends qu'évidemment c'est ce nom pap
ndiaye qui fait couler déjà beaucoup
d'encre les réactions sont extrêmement
vives clément méric dresse le portrait
de celui qui dirigeait jusqu'à présent
le musée de l'immigration la porte dorée
à paris ainsi que celui des nouveaux
visages qui entre pour la première fois
dans cette équipe
c'est donc la surprise de ce nouveau
gouvernement pap ndiaye historien
spécialiste des états unis et des
discriminations raciales
il y a un an il avait pris la tête du
musée de l'histoire de l'immigration
son objectif était alors de regarder en
face le passé colonial de la france mais
sans renoncer à l'universalisme parler
des questions qui sont des questions de
genre ou des questions de race ça n'est
pas une position qui serait opposé aux
lumières et à l'universalisme c'est au
contraire une manière de prendre
sérieusement cette question en estimant
que l'universalisme n'est pas réalisée
pour tout le monde consensuel sur la
forme ses positions sur les questions de
genre ou de race tranche avec celle de
jean michel blanquer frère de la
romancière marie n'diaye il se voit
confier l'un des trois grands chantiers
du quinquennat
une fidèle de jacques chirac au quai
d'orsay pendant près de dix ans
catherine colonna a été la porte parole
de l'elysée le président de la
république a fait de récréation
de 1995 à 2004 c'est elle qui fait le
lien entre le chef de l'état et la
presse dans tous ses déplacements à
l'étranger en 2005 elle devient ministre
délégué aux affaires européennes de
dominique de villepin ces dernières
années catherine colonna a été
ambassadrice de france en italie puis au
royaume uni
son nom circulait déjà pour prendre ce
ministère il ya deux ans conseillère
culture d' emmanuel macron depuis 2019
rima abdul manach est né au liban elle a
d'abord travaillé dans l'humanitaire au
sein de l' ong clowns sans frontières
elle a ensuite rejoint la mairie de
paris d'abord comme conseillère de
l'adjoint à la culture christophe girard
puis comme conseillère culture de
bertrand delanoë
c'est un profil plutôt rare dans la
classe politique une championne de
tennis passé par l'ena c'est d'ailleurs
à l'ena qu'amélie oudéa castéra a connu
emmanuel macron à 44 ans elle prend en
charge les sports mais aussi les jeux
olympiques de paris 2024
sophie de ravinel on va revenir sur ce
visage et ce nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale comment vous
comprenez ce choix il est à 180 degrés
par rapport à jean michel bancaire quand
louis absolument il est à 180 degrés
c'est c'est très clair tout le monde l'a
déjà analysé on a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux montent et les voix contre lui
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
deux de deux possibilités soit en fait
on il ya quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais
résolu avec emmanuel macron c'est ça sur
ce point là sa véritable identité et ce
qui est naturel qu'il en a une ou non
est ce qu'il est les manuels macron de
2017 de sa campagne du rapport aux
femmes voilées qui l'a laissée un peu
émergé pendant cette deuxième campagne
présidentielle ou est-ce qu'il était
plus du côté effectivement de jean
michel blanc guerre de d'un courant
proche ou au sein du printemps
républicain c'est assez compliqué à
savoir est-ce que du coup cette
nomination est dans cette ligne hollande
ou est-ce que c'est tout simplement un
coup d'éclat politique en vue des
législatives parce qu'il faut une
dynamique il faut surtout récupérer
la profession les professeurs il n'y a
jamais eu un aussi grand désamour des
enseignants avec emmanuel macron ont
discuté récemment avec un ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
nous disait que la situation était
catastrophique qu'il fallait absolument
faire quelque chose le chef de l'état un
fait quelque chose est ce que cela va
donner un résultat politique est-ce que
c'est son unique objet on ne s'est pas
remis il a passé comment vous la
comprenez cette nomination est ce qu'on
peut faire du et en même temps sur deux
lignes que tout oppose laïcité
républicaine
universalisme dante égard il ya quelque
chose d'un peu plus je dirais
culturaliste un peu plus du côté de pape
ndiaye n'empêche que ce soir la première
rue elsa le projet sur le papier c'est
samuel pitre complètement métro avec en
miroir avec jean michel blanquer qui
venait évidemment d'en parler je suis
complètement d'accord sur la vision le
positionnement des bagnoles macron qui
très ambivalent sur ces sujets on
l'avait attendu le très longtemps je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais des
mois sur le discours sur la laïcité il
était ambiguë sur le voile en disant on
peut pas reconnaître un bon voilà un
mauvais voile il l'a redit il n'y a pas
très longtemps donc ue par là même dit
qu'on partage et n'est partagée et on
avait souvent l'impression qui faisait
porter ses ministres à jean michel
blanquer d'un côté à gérald darmanin de
l'autre ce qu'il n'arrivait pas à porter
en même temps c'est en même temps un peu
compliqué peut-être que c'est plus
proche de ce qu'il est après sur la
partie politique tactique parce que
c'est évidemment il ya jean luc
mélenchon moi je je je trouve que c'est
un tour de force quand même et
aujourd'hui on l'entend alors déjà la
fusion ce qu'il a réussi à faire à
gauche mais l'entendre aujourd'hui c'est
l'opposant numéro un ça y est il a
dégainé il a défini la dégommer
complètement le gouvernement est à la
limite emmanuel macron lui a donné du
grain à moudre parce qu'il ya pas
tellement c'est de la continuité donc il
peut s'opposer il peut jouer le
référendum le pour ou contre on continue
avec emmanuel macron plat il est
complètement dans son jeu est-ce que
stratégiquement le fait pour emmanuel
macron de récupérer pap ndiaye va lui
permettre de récupérer des gens qui ne
seraient pas trop pour la nuque moi j'y
crois pas trop parce qu'en effet pap
ndiaye va très très loin il avait
tellement parlé de racisme structurel
les retards dans l'état il avait parlé
de violence conjugale je suis pas sûr
que les faits de violences policières
justement là-dessus aussi parce qu'il ya
de quoi dire là dessus aussi pour ce
gouvernement mais bon je suis pas sûr
que les que ces personnalités de gauche
qui n'aimerait pas chez jean luc
mélenchon soient attirés par ce type de
personnalité c'est un stade arrières
jack je vous donne je donne les
réactions des signes la droite qui sont
extrêmement déroulante un marine le pen
la nomination de pap ndiaye indigéniste
assumer à l'éducation nationale et la
dernière pierre de la déconstruction de
notre pays de ses valeurs de son avenir
et puis en ce qui concerne eric zemmour
emmanuel macron avait dit qu'il fallait
déconstruire l'histoire de france pape
ndiaye va s'en charger on est un peu
quand même dans la caricature avec ces
réactions la pap ndiaye c'est leur fils
le père produit de la méritocratie
républicaine absolument mais le
personnage léman où tout cas ses prises
de position ou bien les entendre
justement sur effectivement les
violences policières sur le racisme
d'état appelle ce genre de réaction est
d'ailleurs réconcilie marine le pen eric
zemmour je lé là aussi pour clivé avec
l'opposition de droite avoue avoir à
voir ce qu'il ya derrière cette
domination moi je voudrais quand même
rappeler les prises de position de jean
michel blanquer sur les questions
d'identité elles se sont affirmés gd
radicaliser en tout cas affirmé avec
plus de force tout au long de son de son
passé notamment sept dernières années et
ses prises de position notamment la
création de sons du think tank de jean
michel blanquer
ont profondément irrité emmanuel macron
s'était pas effectivement qu'ils
considéraient que c'était pas la
position d'un ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui avait justement d'autres
choses à gérer qui est visiblement pas
bien géré le fait de jean-michel
bancaire il laisse en bas avec un bilan
de six bâtiments qui prend que peu benêt
de la figure l'exact inverse sur ces
questions effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé d'identité
en amuserait presque le prêt et jambes
là j'étais en très grand risque parce
que maintenant ça reste un immense
ministère extrêmement technique qui va
avoir des écrans de la forme technique a
mené pap ndiaye c'est certes un
intellectuel engagé mais va-t-il savoir
gérer at-il cet aspect de techniciens
pour gérer ce pour mener ses réformes
juste un mot moi je trouve que c'est
assez courageux de sa part de s'engager
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est à la
tête donc de 2,7
mu est assez extraordinaire qu'il a
quand même pris et dont il a la charge
et une charge reconnu il a une image qui
est qui et qui est assez forte a été
nommé par m il avait été nommé par
emmanuel macron il est assez proche de
lui il faut passer il est déjà avant
assez proche de lui et disons qu'il ya
une proximité
d'intellectuels qui qui qui qui viennent
discuter avec emmanuel macron sais c'est
pas quelqu'un qui arrive complètement de
l'extérieur et je trouve ça assez
courageux de sa part de s'engager là
dedans et c'est
celle
du du du primaire du secondaire enfin il
a quelque chose qui va lui manquer la
réforme qui est alors esquissé dans la
campagne par le candidat macro c'est
quand même un peu le big bang c'est
travailler plus pour gagner plus pour
les enseignants le le donnant-donnant
vous vous avez de nouvelles missions
vous serez mieux rémunérés il est
forcément phase avec ça je ne sais pas
s'il est en phase avec ça mais moi j'y
vois une trois prises de risques la
première prise de risque c'est celle
dont a parlé saveria c'est un ministère
de l'éducation nationale c'est un
mystère la fois politiquement
extrêmement technique est en effet c'est
quelqu'un qui vient de l'enseignement
supérieur mais qui ne connaît pas
forcément le primaire et le secondaire
donc il va falloir qu'ils s'adaptent
notamment à la relation contractuelle
avec les syndicats de l'éducation
nationale relation contractuelle qui
était très difficile pour michel
blanquer jean-michel bancaire mais qu'il
connaissait pas ce que jean-michel
bloqueurs avait pratiqué par des postes
de directeurs d'administration centrale
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
depuis traînons depuis de très
nombreuses années ça c'est le premier
point deuxième prise de risque c'est une
prise de risque aussi quand même avec
une partie
j'allais dire de la gauche républicaine
qui est partie intégrante de la macro ni
un mouvement qui parle fait parler
beaucoup de lui attend les siens le
printemps républicains quand même le
grand perdant de tout ce mécano à la
fois d'investiture
politique c'est le printemps
républicains qui ont chacun sait qu'il
est assez proche de manuel valls je ne
suis pas sûr que moi d'un très bon oeil
la nomination de pap ndiaye au ministère
de l'éducation nationale troisième prise
de risque c'est par rapport à l'opinion
publique parce que sur les questions de
laïcité
quand on regarde toutes les études
d'opinion confondues clairement
l'opinion publique aujourd'hui en france
n'est pas forcément sur la ligne qui est
défendu par monsieur ndiaye alors la
vérité c'est que moi je crois
véritablement véritablement c'est que il
en revient à l'origine il en revient à
l'origine du ma chronique sur cette
question c'est 2017 ce qui fait foi à
mes yeux c'est le discours de marseille
en l'occurrence il a été obligé de le
faire évoluer en effet durant le
quinquennat parce qu'il a été confronté
finalement une réalité politique à
laquelle il s'est adapté alors la seule
question qu'il faut se poser est ce que
monsieur pape ndiaye va peut-être
évoluer lui-même c'est-à-dire est-ce que
c'est finalement la question
fondamentale et c'est pour ça que je
vois très bien je vois très bien des
critiques de monsieur mélenchon c'est à
dire c'est lui qui va sa culture est
peut-être un logiciel est peut-être plus
que dirige un goret sport qui correspond
peut-être plus à la laïcité telle que la
défendez monsieur blanc caire et là on
est
c'est une orientation qu'il revienne
elle voulait nous parler de rima abdul
malik oui absolument parce que alors je
ne la connais pas directement j'ai
beaucoup entendu parler d'elle à
l'époque où je suivais la politique à la
ville ville de paris avec bertrand
delanoë et c'est effectivement une de
ses proches et je crois qu'ils
l'apprécient beaucoup je parle pas en
son nom et c'est assez amusant parce que
elle vient rejoindre
même si effectivement
et savait rien l'a très bien dit tout à
l'heure elle était ou peut-être vous
emilie je ne sais plus elle était déjà
conseillère
donc derrière et
un prêt d'emmanuel macro à l'elysée
absolument et donc elle avait déjà un
rôle évidemment très puissant dans
l'ombre elle apparaît aujourd'hui à la
lumière et c'est une personnalité très
intéressante qui a fait preuve d'audace
dans son parcours qui a été apprécié par
tous ceux chez qui elle est passée et lé
fait partie de ce qu'on peut appeler les
bébés delanoë alors on les entend pas
beaucoup autour de 20 dans les cabinets
et on les retrouve dans les cabinets et
il ya aurélien rousseau qui a été
lui-même entre entre guillemets formé
par pierre mans 5 est un ancien adjoint
de bertrand delanoë d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils se sont rencontrés au parti
communiste du 20e arrondissement mais là
c'est un petit peu une autre histoire il
faut savoir qu'à la même époque où un
tout petit peu plus tard elisabeth
bornes elle même était au parti
socialiste à la section du 14e
arrondissement et c'est là même la même
bande alors un peu plus âgés un peu plus
jeunes en tout cas une même ambiance et
un même esprit de travail il ne s'agit
pas d'une coterie comme on a pu dire
d'autre coterie comme il en existe en
politique mais était une même façon
domaine de travailler et une même
engagement dans la machine de paris qui
est une énorme machine administrative et
tout ce sont un peu des techno et elle
quand même parce que la critique est là
aussi horrible abdul molah qu'il va
falloir abus le malin qui va falloir
qu'elle apprenne son métier politique
parce que pour l'instant elle est
d'abord et avant tout une télé
conseillère technique ok alors on va
regarder un petit peu les équilibres
politiques on a commencé à les aborder
la parité aussi la société civile marc
pommier a passé au scanner et ses 27 nom
de l'équipe par un nouveau gouvernement
mais avec l équilibre premier
enseignement l'equilibre droite gauche
et respecté sur le papier parmi les
ministres et ministres délégués 8 sont
de droite sept membres du gouvernement
viennent de la gauche sans oublier les
ministres issus de la société civile là
aussi son set parmi eux pap ndiaye
désormais ministre de l'éducation
nationale
mais quid des ministères régaliens sur
ce point la balance penche clairement
d'un côté la droite rafle les ministères
de l'intérieur de la défense des
affaires étrangères mais aussi de
l'économie et des finances seule la
chancellerie reste du côté de la société
civile eric dupond moretti a été
reconduit garde des sceaux la droite à
la tête des ministères régaliens mais
c'est bien la gauche qui s'occupera du
social avec en perspective des dossiers
compliqués olivier dussopt pts sera
particulièrement scrutée au ministère du
travail c'est lui qui devrait mettre en
oeuvre la réforme des retraites quant à
brigitte bourguignon à la santé elle
devra répondre aux problèmes de pénurie
de soignants à l'hôpital autre équilibre
scruter la parité hommes femmes de ce
côté c'est une égalité parfaite
quatorze hommes 14 femmes en comptant la
première ministre elisabeth bornes mais
dans le détail quatre hommes sont à la
tête des ministères régaliens contre
seulement une femme il s'agit de
catherine colonna qui arrive au quai
d'orsay le très prestigieux ministère
des affaires étrangères
j'aurais qu'on s'arrête sur olivier du
soft qu'on a aperçu dans ce sujet de
marco poney quels défis pour lui c'est
l'explosive réforme des retraites dont
il va hériter il est plutôt discret
emmanuel macron semblent l'apprécier il
était jusqu'ici au budget oui alors à
voir aussi que mon ça va se se définir
avec damien abad qui est en charge lui
des solidarités de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées donc avoir acquis
va incomber c'était effectivement ce
dossier des retraites ça serait plus
olivier du soap et j'ai dit stop c'est
un c'est un socialiste il vient de la
gauche il est
franc fort et en plus c'est
effectivement une grosse formation je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a
véritablement la confiance du président
emmanuel macron la cité récemment dans
un discours donc c'est une vraie
promotion pour celui qui était jusque là
en charge du budget à noter aussi que le
budget les comptes publics est un autre
ministère important qui incombera
peut-être environnement à gabriel
attaque aussi une promotion pour
débrayer la table et me rappelle ce qui
les retraites les retraites c'est sera
pilotée quand même par elisabeth bornes
ce que je dis a commencé assez justement
cette espèce de vision subliminale de la
réforme des retraites parce que c'était
quand même quelque chose une bombe qu'a
place emmanuel macron dans sa conférence
de presse là je reviens au premier tour
quoi campagne premier tour cette très
courte campagne qu'il a fait et il avait
posé quand même cette banque de la
réforme des retraites comme le rsa
conditionné entre autres
on il a senti que ça faisait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de remous et pendant
l'entre-deux-tours les syndicats
contrôle voilà pendant votre deux tours
il a bien modifié pour répondre beaucoup
plus à une approche sociale ça va être
compliqué cette réforme de retraites on
le voit bien qu est ce qu elle a
commencé à faire elisabeth borne son
premier déplacement pas du tout été sas
a pas été du tout sur ce plan là ça a
été sur des jeunes femmes ça a été sur
l'éducation pouvoir progresser continuer
la bataille pour ces jeunes filles donc
aux mureaux un territoire quand même pas
facile donc elle a complètement effacé
cette réforme des retraites et je pense
que c'était assez malin parce que on a
bien vu qu'emmanuel macron si on en
croit les rumeurs et les approches des
journalistes a eu beaucoup de refus de
personnalités de gauche j'allais dire de
vraies personnalités de gauche parce
qu'obligés du soft oui mais il est déjà
il est déjà dans la macro ni c'est pas
une prise de gauche il y en a pas eu de
prise de gauche comment porter une
réforme si connoté à droite pour une
personnalité de gauche eh bien il n'a
pas trouvé emmanuel macron finalement
c'est à chercher à ce qu'il a cherché
sgd refus en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a
entendu dire est en tout cas le résultat
c'est qu'il ya pas de personnalités de
gauche nouvelles qui viennent dans le
dans le gouvernement on prend olivier
dussopt pts qui a très bien fait le job
d'une manière assez discrète mais assez
méthodique un peu à la lisabeth bornes
c'est à dire je fais des choses j'avance
très discrètement qu'il
véritable voilà à moins qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui soit nommé comme il
l'avait fait auparavant sur la réforme
des retraites on va voir comment il
entraîne ce mécanisme mais juste dernier
point ça va être compliqué de la vente
cette réforme même si on le prend sur
l'aspect social ce qu'ils ont commencé à
faire et que manuel m'a quand même
l'impression qui viendra parler
davantage un peu plus centre gauche
alors que la droite de la macro n'y
aurait voulu que cette réforme ça
portait pour son électorat wii est la
même en même temps récompense personne
enfin ne satisfait personne parce que
c'est pas entendable parce que les
français n'en veulent pas de cette
réforme les syndicats n'en veulent pas
et même si on fait de l'explication
texte ça passe pas il ya quelque chose
qui n'arrive pas à passer d'un maquereau
née de la première heure
bien bien servi à tal bonne guérini oui
elle est plutôt présente elle est plutôt
clairement présente mais moi ce que je
pense c'est que tu as volé ce
gouvernement il a aussi et c'est toute
la stratégie qu d'emmanuel macron depuis
finalement sa réélection c'est d'essayer
de couper la route de la gauche il va
couper il veut couper la route de la
gauche en envoyant des signaux mais des
signaux de communication en la matière
c'est madame board nommé premier
ministre c'est madame bandes qui se
déplace aux mureaux sur des terres
chances apparaissent comme des terres
plutôt favorable à la gauche c'est
aujourd'hui la nomination de monsieur
pape ndiaye qu'on n'attendait pas au
ministère de l'éducation nationale donc
ce soit ces signaux qu'ils envoient et
lors du sommet c'est triste cette norme
et c'est plutôt habile bill sort parce
que faire porter une réforme de droite à
un angle de gauche en général on peut
considérer que le vecteur sera plus
efficace que si c'est porté par monsieur
hamad croit qu'il faudra quand même se
poser la question quel sera le
positionnement de monsieur à bach dans
la réforme parce que votre base il est
quand un ministre est solide et
on peut imaginer qu'il y ait un binôme
finalement abad un soft qui mène cette
réforme des retraites mais sur la
réforme des retraites elle va être
dépendante du résultat des législatives
évidemment c'est ça qui va être
évidemment du résultat d'elisabeth
bornes d'abord est-ce qu'elle va être
élu dans le calvados et lequel n'a pas
être élue si elle n'est pas élue il ya
des chances qu'elles ne restent pas si
elle ne réduit pas à ce moment là
sa verrière jacques allez-y non allez on
vous parle effectivement de deux centre
gauche où on récompense effectivement
certaines figures issues de la gauche
même si c'était il y à un moment moi
j'ai aussi le sentiment qu'on récompense
et que les mystères les plus importants
notamment les régalien vos personnalités
issues de la droite les anciens proches
effectivement des leurs philippe que
sont notamment sébastien lecornu
les armées ce qui est une énorme
promotion pour ce il faut se dire que je
l'année quoi gérald darmanin qui est
confortée bruno le maire qui est
confortée enfin voila c'est quand même
et tout ça sont des figures de figures
issues de la droite oreilles je voudrais
vous parler de ce tandem vous l'évoquiez
savait rien amélie de montchalin agnès
pannier rue nash et la planification
écologique sera porté par ces deux
femmes la première va s'occuper à la
fois des territoires de la transition
écologique la deuxième de la transition
énergétique sous la houlette d'élisabeth
bornes comme nous l'expliquent thibault
enoch regarder
trois femmes pour un défi l'écologie aux
côtés de la première ministre elisabeth
bornes directement responsable de la
planification écologique
deux autres femmes seront en charge de
cette mission madame agnès pannier une
hache et
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame amélie de montchalin
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
deux femmes récompensées et promu pour
fidèles et loyaux services et qui ont
fait leurs preuves aux yeux du président
elle était déjà ministre sous le
gouvernement de jean castex l'une amis
espagnols une hache et à l'industrie
l'autre amélie de montchalin à la
fonction publique il y a quelques
semaines cette dernière dresser le
portrait robot du candidat idéal sur
notre antenne cet homme ou cette femme
aura des responsabilités majeures sur
l'écologie compétences déjà amené un
immense projet d'organisation à la fois
gouvernementales et du pays dans son
ensemble et les élus il faudra cette
personne soit en particulier très habile
dans sa capacité à conserver le rôle des
deux ministres mettre en oeuvre la
promesse d' emmanuel macron de doubler
la réduction de gaz à effet de serre
sous ce quinquennat premier pilier
l'énergie agnès pannier une hache et
devra a lancé le programme nucléaire
souhaité par le président tout en
poussant les feux sur le renouvelable
côté mis aujourd'hui enfreint en place
pour être au rendez vous de la réduction
des émissions carbone à horizon 2030 et
pour la neutralité carbone à horizon
2050 en ce qui concerne amélie de
montchalin la ministre de la transition
écologique devra réussir la
planification écologique territoriale
voulue par emmanuel macron notamment
dans le domaine des transports et du
logement pour réussir ces chantiers le
principal enjeu pour les deux ministres
et la première mini sera la méthode pour
son deuxième quinquennat emmanuel macron
veut éviter le piège d'une écologie
punitive est imposée qui avait provoqué
la crise de gilet jaune le mot d'ordre
sera la concertation
soucier de ravinel de femmes promues qui
n'ont rien d'écolo dans leur parcours
vous qui suivez les écologistes pour le
figaro ça va être très compliqué un
petit peu compliqué les premières
réactions sont très dures faut le dire
elles sont assez dures dire mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette blague de femmes
est la seule à qui on reconnaît un tout
petit peu de coloration écologique c'est
évidemment elisabeth bornes en se disant
de toute façon puisque elle a occupé
aussi le poste en se disant de toute
façon c'est elle qui va décider elles
vont appliquer ou c'est emmanuel macron
qui décidera et quelques décidera-t-il
mais en tout cas ces nominations c'est
c'est tous les nominés merci qu'aucune
prise et colonel - étaient possibles
alors c'est possible que ce soit sans
c'est possible que yannick jadot est
refusé il est possible qu'ils aient eu
d'autres propositions qui était fait
mais en l'occurrence c'est ça va à
contre-courant indue du petit minuscule
card début d'espoir qu'il ya pu y avoir
avec le discours d' emmanuel macron
pendant sa campagne et là la réponse
elle est assez violente c'est une vaste
blague donc le lien qui était rompue
n'est pas du tout moi je pourrais me
remettre en question un petit peu les
volontés écolo de d'emmanuel macro et
déjà eu quand même la star nicolas hulot
voilà donc je pense qu'il voulait pas
rejouer cette espèce de figure très
populaire mais ce qui n'a pas donné du
tout de résolu d'attention et même ça a
été contre-productif quand même un
ministre qui finit par quasiment pleurer
en disant j'ai pas les mains libres je
fais pas ce que je veux je pars c'était
quand même assez compliqué là on a deux
personnalités en effet pas du tout
connoté écolo alors peut-être un petit
peu en espagne et une hache et de son
poste de ministre de l'industrie sur la
décarbonation d'industrie donc une
vision très critique les industriels à
part les récollets de l'écologie
industrielle
c'est une façon particulière de prendre
l'écologie pourquoi pas d'ailleurs si on
est très très loin de là des croix c'est
une façon fut libéré c'est une façon
c'est un peu les mêmes allés jusqu'à la
décroissance non mais c'est une façon
alors pourtant c'est qu'il a été de
gauche mais c'est presque l'écologie de
droite c'est à dire de faire ça par les
entreprises et par l'écologie un mini
relation en tout cas il connaît un petit
peu ce cas-là ameline montchanin alors
je sais pas du tout mais j'ai pas du
tout l'impression qu'il ya un sujet et
d'écologie c'est en effet j'ai
l'impression des machines de guerre pour
réaliser des réformes comme elisabeth
bornes maintenant est ce qu'elles vont
être capables d'amener leurs pattes ça
serait intéressant ça serait mais c'est
peut-être une écologie différentes on
récompense deux ministres macro nist
techno efficace dû répondre et fuir
cache absolument très efficace pendant
la pandémie notamment agnès manière une
hache et qui est très apprécié à bercy
dont elle vient également pour un
million chalain c'est effectivement
alors il n'y a pas d'effets whaou n'y a
pas de figure alibi étendard comme a pu
l'être effectivement nicolas hulot lors
du début du premier quinquennat c'est
deux techniciennes c'est une écologie de
résultats emmanuel macron c'est sans
doute résolu à ça peut-être
effectivement dans les premiers temps il
cherchait plutôt une figure plus mme et
éthique plus rassembleuse et il s'est
résolu à ses techniciens alors ce sont
deux femmes c'est des femmes de
résultats je pense qu'on peut aussi leur
laisser le beignet
sous la route est effectivement
d'elisabeth bornes qui on le rappelle a
été
logique donc voilà sont deux très bonne
technicienne en charge de cette question
jusque là parce qu'on pour le dire c'est
quand même compliqué cette ambition
écologique moi j'ai moi j'y crois pas
trop qui a une véritable envie
quelque soit l portant mais en tout cas
ce qui est unique et et moi je me
demande quel gouvernement portera
vraiment cette écologie parce que on a
le pouvoir d'achat qui se confrontent à
cette question là et l'écologie même si
moi je considère que c'est un
investissement ça coûte de l'argent donc
c'est un moment très compliqué dans la
fois répondre à cette demande en fait
comme bout d'un mois s'il en coûte
permanent pour parce qu'il ya des
préoccupations avec la gare en ukraine
etc questions d'énergie il ya des
temporalités voilà la gueule car
il ya cette transition à faire mais qui
va nous coûter quand même beaucoup il
faut lui souhaiter la mise et où
seraient tombés des ti
et rick dupond moretti le garde des
sceaux vous qui connaissez bien les
milieux politiques parlementaires
proches du proche du droit comment vous
comprenez qu'il ait réussi à
sauver sa place il a tout la
magistrature contre lui il ya des
soupçons de prise illégale d'intérêts
qui pèsent aussi sur ses épaules dans la
sphère des écoutes c'est vraiment une
surprise alors il ya 2 il ya deux
éléments qui peuvent éventuellement
expliquer d'abord vous savez emmanuel
macron est un homme de fidélité c'est à
dire que il lâche rarement ceux qui le
soutiennent ce point de vue là il a un
profil assez mitterrandien c'est à dire
souvenez-vous moment de la sphère
benalla il y en a 8 ans a lâché monsieur
benalla eh bien monsieur aujourd'hui
dupond moretti c'est quelqu'un auquel
finalement le président de la république
accorde sa confiance parce qu'ils
considèrent vraisemblablement que c'est
aussi une personnalité je crois
du charisme un autre aspect c'est que ce
gouvernement est un gouvernement qui
doit aller jusqu'aux élections
législatives donc on peut peut-être
aussi imaginer que on a besoin de
laisser en place ce monsieur dupont
moretti parce qu'en plus c'est une
caution de gauche dans les ministères
régaliens monsieur mérite il n'y a pas
un seul ministre régalien qui échappe à
la droite donc il faut aussi trouver
quelqu'un qui d'une certaine manière
emblématique cette caution de gauche et
dupond moretti peut-être que jusqu'aux
élections légistatives c'est la bonne
personne après on verra ensuite ce qui
se passera après ces élections
législatives je rappellerai que j'avais
entre deux gouvernements en 20 81
françois mitterrand dont maurice fort
garde des sceaux
un mois plus tard il nomme robert
badinter ça fait driving elle et je vais
parler sa santé serait viable mais je
pense qu emmanuel macron voit aussi
montrer aux magistrats qui c'est raoul
c'est qui qui commande dans cette
évolution dans ce bras de fer entre
quand même manière les la justice est
bien quand même oui c'est lui qui est le
chef et c'est la séparation des pouvoirs
et c'est lui qui décide il ya un bras de
fer emmanuel macron ne peut pas perdre
la face et le fait de maintenir et
dupond moretti contre eux qui pour
l'instant nous il n'y a aucune charge
qui judiciaire qui l'obligerait à
quitter le gouvernement
enfin c'était une promesse de bail
macron version 2010 est quand même l'un
de l'andorre mais sans éclat pour
l'instant on attend moi j'ai vous a
gardé sous est mis en examen oui moi je
parlais fidélité à l'élève en attendant
d'avoir le dernier mot sur cette
histoire des conflits d'intérêts non
mais je sais parler de fidélité aux
personnalités mais pas de fidélité à ses
idées parce que je n'en mets pour
l'instant l'annoncé dans un enjeu
l'exemplarité
l'exemplarité c'était une promesse d'
emmanuel macron qui disait comme en
effet beaucoup avant lui qu'on va faire
on va faire complètement différemment il
y aura pas de mise en examen françois
bayrou dès le début qui a dû sauter
parce qu'ils étaient mises en examen un
emploi fictif et puis là tout d'un coup
oui mais là tout d'un coup on accepte
tout moi j'ai l'impression qu'il est
fidèle jusqu'au dernier moment on l'a vu
dernièrement avec des candidats aux
législatives
on a on a vu qu'il attendait le dernier
moment pour enlever jérôme peyrat pour
que thierry solère aussi qui est mise en
examen et qui a je sais pas combien de
chefs d'accusation je pourrais même pas
les compter je crois 13
comment ça
c'est choquant je pense qu'on est à un
moment de la démocratie où il ya des
populations il ya des citoyens qui
remettent en question tout ça et là on
refait éternellement les mêmes choses on
attend le dernier moment pour débrancher
les gens parce que tout d'un coup on se
dit oh là là c'est quand même compliqué
de dire si ça c'est un honnête homme
alors qu'il a envie de lui remet en
scène du gard moretti les gens
s'arrêtaient ou par dupont moretti fait
partie avec d'autres notamment olivier
ferrand des irritants si je peux me
permettre de ce gouvernement ce taire
ceux qui pour x raisons ne devait pas
rester dans le nouveau gouvernement
notamment parce que voilà il ya une très
mauvaise entente avec des magistrats
parce qu'il n'a pas de récit bascule à
paris il n'a pas voulu donc à fayet nous
verrons aussi soft
déranger l'image deux ans de pandémie il
fallait bon néanmoins ce qui a rendu
extrêmement est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup
plus énervé le président la république
c'est lors de la cérémonie d'investiture
les plus hautes figures de la
magistrature française ont refusé de s'y
rendre bon justement protester contre le
maintien
d'eric dupond-moretti car visiblement
encore plus énervé le chef de l'état est
renvoyé des brasseurs alors qu'il
s'était résolu à elle plutôt se séparer
du cadet des fils du garde chasse et à
deux jours de son agacement a décidé de
le garder je crois également que
brigitte macron agile chose à mort ah
oui oui mais sans que ce soit un rôle
décisif mais je vois là alors il reste
une poignée de minutes j'aurais qu'on
évoque la droite mais d'abord un petit
son duel brawn peavey justement son son
nom était donné pour pour la place
vendôme pour la justice c'est finalement
l'outre-mer elle avait des ambitions
aussi pour le perchoir quittera donc
l'assemblée la présidence de la
commission des lois on va l'écouter
en premier lieu c'est vraiment de même
attaché à la question sanitaire il est
impératif que l'on regarde bien et qu'on
soit le plus protecteur possible de
toutes les populations
donc c'est le premier dossier que je
vais regarder attentivement dès ce soir
voilà et puis pour terminer le cas de
damien abad jusqu'au bout gouvernement
pas gouvernement il a préparé le terrain
il a quitté la présidence du groupe
parlementaire ici à l'assemblée il est
fidèlement chargée de la solidarité de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées du
coup du coup ses anciens collègues des
républicains s'amuse à exhumer certain
nombre de critiques qu'il avait à
l'encontre par exemple tiens tiens de
eric woerth écoutez à l'infidélité
s'ajoutent l'inélégance de ce départ
parce que la réalité c'est que les
républicains ont travaillé pendant cinq
ans d'ailleurs il a activement participé
à ce travail nous avons combattu la
réforme des retraites du gouvernement
nous avons combattu tous les budgets de
ce gouvernement ou dénoncer les dérives
de la dépense le manque de maîtrise des
déficits et de la dette donc voilà la
vérité c'est qu'on assiste à un mercato
moi j'aime pas quand on change d'équipé
en cours de match grand l'expliqué
politique je l'expliquent c'est à lui de
dire je comprends pas il n'y a pas
d'explication au fondée il ya toujours
un peu d'opportunisme politique
électorale là dedans c'est dommage parce
que c'est de la tambouille politicienne
et ça éloigne toujours plus les français
de la politique ah ouais ça fait
toujours mal de sortir de dakar archives
là il s'agit du compte twitter des
républicains damien abad bon qu'est ce
que c'est quoi c'est un débauchage
individuel
oui ça faisait déjà singing peut-être
tuf la dernière passerelle qui
pourraient y pour être un peu plus
importante était attendu quand même
c'était attendu depuis quelques semaines
on parlait de lui on parlait de son nom
etc mais j'étais en reportage avec une
députée l air en réunion publique etc
qui était on a une réunion
d'appartements et tout le monde est
aimée effondrés après nicolas sarkozy
damien abad et la député en question
étaient aussi en train de se dire mais
enfin voilà c'est comme c'est un coup de
grâce alors évidemment ces déclarations
font de font pitié et sans sont
terribles a piqué au sens souvent on se
dit le pauvre il doit s se réécouter
mais c'est vrai que c'est la continuité
de ce pont et que les choses vont
s'atténuer on va voir quels résultats ou
les paiements pour terminer les
législatives c'est le juge de paix dans
cette affaire on nous disait que ça
n'est qu'une peut-être qu'une première
copie du gouvernement alors fait une
tradition vous présenter aux élections
vous vous perdez vous partez mais ça
n'est pas fondamentalement la règle la
règle législatives est-ce que comment
vous voyez la suite il faudra tenir
tenir compte des résultats alors
elisabeth borne pour le coup dans le
calvados je crois c'est plutôt une
circonscription où ça devrait passer ça
devrait passer je crois que celui qui le
plus le plus en difficulté c'est
peut-être clément bonne à paris où c'est
effectivement assez eux
il est quand même dans l'arrondissement
qui lui est le plus favorable oui mais à
plein d'égards annonay les détient mais
avec les règles qui conte les grès des
règles consistait à faire démissionner
les ministres qui étaient battus n'ont
pas été respectées lors des élections
régionales tout et que s'il ya vu un
grand nombre de ministres qui était
candidat aux élections régionales et à
malte il a aucun qui a été nuls et donc
on verra si les ministres éventuellement
battus garderont leur poste je me
souviens mois 2 alain juppé ministre de
l'écologie de nicolas sarkozy ministre
d'état qui est battu à bordeaux et qui
doit démissionner
pour ce rappel merci infiniment pour ce
grand tour d'horizon jour de ce nouveau
gouvernement que vous avez brillamment
analysé merci merci à vous on va
continuer d'ailleurs d'en parler d'une
certaine manière avec nos affranchis
qu'on accueille tout de suite pour leur
parti pris j'ai nommé elsa monde un
gamma pour son carnet de campagne
quotidien sur les législatives viendront
ensuite richard berry regard européen de
richard que ce soir sur notre nouvelle
première ministre elisabeth bornes vu
d'europe qu'est ce que ça donne et va
nous dire dans un instant et puis
l'économie avec fanny guinochet accord
le gel des loyers
l'inflation est terrible elle frappe de
plein fouet et les locataires modestes
nous affranchit les voici bonsoir
bonsoir
qui a beaucoup travaillé comme hier
entre les sujets les chroniques vous
nous raconter ce soir les coulisses de
la campagne des législatives comme tous
les jours et vous faites un peu de
généalogie car la politique c'est aussi
une affaire de famille oui et ça touche
tous les camps politiques on va
commencer dans la majorité pierre baudis
par exemple est investi dans la première
circonscription de haute garonne c'est
le fils de dominique baudis qui lui
aussi
le sait a été député maire de toulouse
il pourrait y avoir 2 15 9 pour le prix
dans l'hémicycle le père et le fils rien
à voir avec l'ancien ministre bernard
cazeneuve jean rené casenave il est
candidat à sa réélection dans le gers et
son fils pierre dans les hauts-de-seine
à droite cette fois la mort d'olivier
dassault son siège de député est restée
dans la famille puisque son neveu victor
habert dassault a été élu et il est
candidat à sa succession
dans la famille le pen je demande cette
fois la soeur marie caroline elle se
présente dans les hauts-de-seine et puis
chez la nuque le gendre de jean luc
mélenchon gabriel amard à lui été
investis à villeurbanne et puis l on l'a
appris hier soir thierry solère députés
les républicains passé chez emmanuel
macron qui me conseiller à l'elysée ne
sera finalement pas candidat dans les
hauts-de-seine on en dise un mot tout à
l'heure exactement officiellement après
dix années au parlement il s'est engagé
il est temps pour lui de poursuivre son
engagement politique sous une forme
nouvelle thierry solère vous en avez
parlé c'est un proche des manuels macron
c'est lui qui lui a servi de rabatteur
pour débaucher à droite thierry solère
il est aussi mise en cause par la
justice mises en examen pour 13 chefs
d'accusation de fraude fiscale ont fini
par une annonce dans la montagne
françois hollande alors candidat ou pas
alors il y avait plus vraiment de
suspense mais il l'a confirmé dans les
colonnes de la montagne il ne sera pas
candidat il n'a pas de raison de l'être
puisqu'il ya une bien une candidature
dissidente à celle de la nuque on le
sait l'ancien chef de l'état s'était
montré très critique contre cet accord
et puis le dépôt des listes on l'a vu
c'était dernier carat ce soir 18h lui il
a attendu le dernier moment pour le
faire guillaume pelletier vice-président
exécutif de reconquête est candidat à sa
succession il n'est pas du tout assurée
gagner celle ci reconnaît eric zemmour
n'a obtenu que 8 % des voix quand marine
le pen a fait 31 % au premier tour les
infos coulisses d'elsa monde un gavage
sur ces législatives c'est jusqu'au
deuxième tour c'est à dire le 19 juin
prochain celui tous les soirs dans ça
vous regarde richard on continue à
parler politiquement soir à vous bonsoir
on en parle on en reparle à notre
première ministre elisabeth bornes
suscite beaucoup de réactions en france
on parle d'une techno plutôt marquée à
gauche vu d'europe qu'est ce que ça
donne déjà est ce qu'on la connaît et
sinon j'ai l'impression qu'on peut est
ce que c'est si grave eh bien oui c'est
peut-être g myriam à langer fait le tour
j'ai fait le tour d'abord des médias
européens de collègues correspondant
j'ai même passé des coups de fil à
bruxelles eh bien il faut l'avouer
personne ne connaît c'est elisabeth
bornes avant qu'elle soit nommé à
matignon sauf évidemment quelques
confrères qui al'occasion couvrez les
conseils européens pour les transports
puisque vous savez que c'est un domaine
qu'elle agirait comme ministre mais à
part ça personne ne la connaissait alors
vous me direz que c'était déjà le cas de
jean castex alors là c'était moins
étonnant monsieur jean castex personne
ne connaissait en france non plus donc
on peut le comprendre et puis c'est
aussi la logique répondons à bruxelles
parce que dans le système français qui
est très présidentiel de toute manière
tout tournait autour d' emmanuel macron
d'autant qu'il est en ce moment
président tournant de l'union européenne
il se sera jusqu'à la fin juin mais tout
de même pas mal de partenaires européens
de la france s'interroge parce que tout
le monde sait qu emmanuel macron il est
saturé avec l'ukraine il a les yeux
rivés vers l'ukraine il a le téléphone
avec vladimir poutine et pourtant il ya
d'autres sujets qu'il faut négocier ils
y allaient fuji énergétique très
important alors à priori c'est elisabeth
bornes mais on ne sait pas vraiment ce
qu'elle en pense et puis il ya d'autres
sujets qui m'ont prêté comme la réforme
l'énième réforme de la politique
agricole commune on est quand même en
pleine crise alimentaire mondiale alors
vous imaginez myriam dans ce cas vers
qui se tourner les européens vers bruno
le maire et bien oui eh bien oui bruno
le maire le ministre des finances celui
qu'à bruxelles on appelle un peu le
wolfgang schauble français vous savez
chat aux bleus a été pendant longtemps
le ministre allemand des finances
effectivement les deux interlocuteurs
qui sont connus c'est d'une part bruno
le maire et d'autre part clément bon
évidemment qui vient des promus
puisqu'il sera maintenant ministre
délégué
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu elisabeth
borgne a démérité encore une fois ceux
qui l'ont fréquenté au conseil
transports trouve qu'elle connaissait
très bien ses dossiers mais la vérité
c'est que l'atout femmes en europe ce
qui plaît en france en europe finalement
c'est devenu très ordinaire regarder les
chefs de gouvernements scandinaves se
sont toutes des femmes on l'a vu avant
exactement président des cui et puis il
ya même des femmes journalistes qui sont
peut-être plus méchante que nous les
hommes regarder ma consoeur du soir de
bruxelles à paris qui écrit pas de
grands pas en avant ni de moment
historique il y a surtout un président
qui souhaitait tenir le gouvernail du
pouvoir entre ses seules mains avec à
ses côtés un parfait exécutant fidèle
loyal vue de côté de la cause féminine
il s'agirait même presque d'une
caricature dit la correspondante du soir
ça fait du bien qu'on nous dise les
choses clairement mais néanmoins ils
arrêtent un avantage parce que sa
connaissance des dossiers et aussi son
côté austère finalement ça rassure à
bruxelles on aime bien quand les
français sont austères puisque
d'habitude on leur prête d'autres
qualités mais aussi parce que ceux qui
connaissent les dossiers communautaires
savent que beaucoup de choses se passent
à matignon quand il s'agit d'europe
parce que c'est un maquignon qui est
rattaché le secrétariat général pour les
affaires européennes c'est là que les
fonctionnaires français à bruxelles
viennent chercher leurs oeufs leurs
consignes alors je laisserais pour
terminer la parole au times de londres
qui quand même a dit à propos d isabelle
borne de toute manière en france quand
les choses vont bien le président reçoit
les applaudissements et lorsqu'elle
tourne mal le premier ministre en assume
la responsabilité permettant au chef de
l'état de prendre de la hauteur bon
courage elizabeth ça s'appelle un
paratonnerre essais signés général de
gaulle afin qu'elles république merci
beaucoup ri charge précise que vous êtes
le correspondant dorénavant du quotidien
suisse alémanique blick et on est ravi
pour tout à fait en français et en
allemand s'il vous plaît fanny
l'économie ce soir ce sont les loyers
les loyers qui à face à l'inflation
augmente et les locataires modestes qui
trinque alors le gouvernement
réfléchirait à un gel des loyers oui
c'est une piste sérieuse sur laquelle
planche bercy donc bruno le maire
qui sera dans la continuité
l'idée c'est de limiter la hausse des
loyers puisque en bloquant l'indicé de
référence des loyers cet indice de
référence des loyers il est indexé sur
l'inflation donc forcément il augmente
avec les prix de la consommation et cet
indice de référence et la base de calcul
des propriétaires pour pouvoir vous
augmentez votre loyer chaque année alors
l'idée c'est de bloquer les tarifs un
peu comme on l'a fait pour le gaz ou
l'électricité
il faut dire que selon l'insee on
rappelle que les loyers ont pris déjà
deux et demi pour cent depuis le début
de l'année et on s'attend à une hausse
qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 5% à la fin
d'année ce qui fait quand même un budget
très lourd parce que augmente et éloigne
et plusieurs dizaines
d'euros alors surtout que le
budget logement c'est un énorme budget
c'est 25% de ce que dépense chaque mois
les ménages il ya 40 millions de
locataires en france et pour eux c'est
un break ou au porte monnaie alors là
l'inquiétude des associations de
consommateurs elle a et elle pousse le
gouvernement à agir très vite dès le 1er
juillet en faveur qu'un bras de fer
quand même qu'il se joue il ya
évidemment un bras terre parce que de
l'autre côté il ya des propriétaires et
des bailleurs sociaux et aussi on bloque
les loyers bas forcé ment il ment perdre
de l'argent et eux ils expliquent que
ils ont déjà d'énormes charges qu'ils
supportent que ce soit la hausse de la
taxe foncière 3% en moyenne cette année
l'ovation des rénovations aussi des
logements il ya eu des nouvelles
réglementations
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'à 61 % des
ménages français qui sont propriétaires
et tous ne sont pas des normes
propriétaire il ya des petits
propriétaires qui louent un logement et
c'est pour eux une source de revenus un
complément de revenu qui est
indispensable du coup il ya une
tentation pour les propriétaires de
laisser leurs logements vides c'est
possible c'est aussi faire un problème
c'est un vrai problème donc c'est aussi
là dessus que je joue les associations à
disant attention si on ne fait pas
quelque chose si on ne fait pas un coup
de pouce eh bien on va avoir des
propriétaires qui vont sortir du parc
leur appartement et ça va être encore
plus difficile pour les français de se
loger les propriétaires de leur côté eux
disent effectivement ce serait la goutte
d'eau ce gel des loyers qui ferait
déborder phase alors les pistes sont sur
la table pour le pour le texte pouvoir
d'achat ça sera le paquet législatif
alentours dans le paquet législatif du
mois de juillet c'est effectivement très
sûr maintenant reste à savoir où mettre
le curseur par exemple en espagne
un blocage des loyers il vient d'être
décidée à 2% pendant trois mois c'est
temporaire d'autres disent plutôt que de
cibler tous les locataires peut-être que
la solution ce serait de bloquer les
loyers des locataires les plus modestes
mais là c'est un casse tête technique
sur lequel planche bersier en tout cas
on va suivre parce que ça va être un des
dossiers prioritaires du gouvernement eh
bien merci merci à vous les affranchis
vous en pensez-quoi juste vu de suisse
de ce nouveau gouvernement je ne sais
pas demandez pas tellement de surprises
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est là dessus
que j'ai fait ma première chronique
c'est l'importance quand même de gérald
darmanin et de bruno le maire qui plus
que jamais apparaissent comme les
mousquetaires du président on se demande
pour le protéger de quoi on voulait avec
plaisir merci merci à vous c'est la fin
de cette émission va se retrouver et
bien la semaine prochaine puisque c'est
celle week-end tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire avec la z c'est la
zone d'education documentaire de valérie
brochard vous le savez elle propose un
documentaire à des collégiens de 3e ce
soir c'est la seine saint denis et
qu'elle a dit voir de mon maire très
belle soirée profitez bien patrick head
[Musique]